I’ve always sucked at yoga, I have like
zero balance, but maybe I should give it another
try.
Hey guys Julia here for DNews
Over 20 Million Americans practice yoga.
I’m pretty sure most of that’s just in
the Bay Area.
That figure comes from a study published in
Yoga Journal.
According to their survey the top reasons
for starting yoga were: flexibility, general
conditioning, stress relief, and to improve
overall health and physical fitness.
Yoga is deeply rooted in Hindu tradition,
where a series of postures and breathing exercises
prepares the body for meditation and connecting
with the divine.
There’s a lot more to yoga than striking
a few poses.
Traditional yoga is a whole spiritual practice
with 8 parts including a code of ethical standards
and studying scriptures.
Only one of those parts, asana, involves poses.
Not surprisingly, yoga has been stripped down
and repackaged to Americans as a form of exercise.
But apart from the cultural appropriation,
Yoga is actually pretty good for you.
Let’s look at what the science says.
Chronic pain can reduce or change grey matter
in the brain which can lead to some serious
problems like memory and emotional issues.
But according to an official at the National
Institutes of Health (NIH), practicing yoga
has the opposite effect on the brain.
So what does the brain look like on Yoga?
Well study after study reportedly heralds
the benefits of Yoga.
Researchers from Boston University School
of Medicine found that the postures from Yoga
actually increases the amount of gamma-aminobutyric
acid or GABA in the brain.
GABA, a neurotransmitter, calms the nervous
system and regulates muscle tone.
In one study the researchers found that after
just one hour of Yoga, practitioners GABA
levels increased by 27%.
This increase in GABA levels could be responsible
for decreasing anxiety and improving mood
in those who practice yoga.
Another small study published in the Journal
of Physical Activity and Health found that
after short, 20 minute sessions of Hatha yoga
participants performed better on tests of
brain function.
They could focus better, process information
faster, and even learn more effectively than
after a typical aerobic exercise like running
on a treadmill.
The researchers think that by focusing on
the body, posture or breath, you push out
any distracting thoughts and or reduce some
stress, both of which could increase cognitive
function.
But it’s not just your brain that gets a
boost.
Researchers from the US and the Netherlands
found that yoga could help those with cardiovascular
disease.
Published in the European Journal of Preventive
Cardiology, the researchers reviewed 37 different
studies.
They found that yoga improves risk factors
for heart disease similar to the effects of
typical exercise.
Some studies showed that it lowered body weight,
cholesterol and heart rate.
Other researchers think yoga can ease pain
by enhancing both the toning of muscles and
releasing of muscle tension.
Even sufferers of Multiple sclerosis, or MS,
a potentially debilitating autoimmune disease,
that affects the brain and central nervous
system found some relief from yoga.
Researchers from Rutgers University conducted
a small trial where MS patients participated
in a 8 week long specialized yoga program.
After completing the program patients had
better mental health, concentration, bladder
control, walking, and vision, with a decrease
in pain and fatigue.
There’s other studies that show it could
reduce inflammation, help with hypertension
or those who live with pain from fibromyalgia
or arthritis.
Just know there’s a lot of research happening
within the past five years and a lot of it’s
positive.
Speaking of questionably trendy healthy fads…
what’s the deal with kale?
If you’re craving some kale.. watch this
episode first…
Have you ever tried yoga?
I did for a few months.
I have like no balance, so the instructor
would call me out and tell me to go use the
wall.
So yeah.
Tell us your stories down in the comments
below.